okay so the mcu is easily the most
successful franchise in hollywood often
imitated but never duplicated it
consistently knocks it out the park and
has provided us with incredible stories
and also amazing characters when we look
at the mcu as a whole it's outstanding
what they managed to achieve and whilst
most studios struggle to make a sequel
that feels like it's part of a unified
franchise marvel have crafted over 20
films that all tie together perfectly
over the last decade we've had several
faces introduced and the franchises
catapulted complete unknowns to become
household names now the one at the
center of this is of course tony stark
who has made an icon due to robert
downey jr's performance casting rdj was
a massive risk and if he grew up in the
90s you'd probably remember that he was
arrested several times and that he
battled with addiction in a very public
space whilst he's often looked at
negatively for this you have to give the
guy his props as he's managed to come
through the other side of it and in many
ways he's a shining example of how one
can overcome their own demons this is
why the role of tony stark seems like it
was made for him in the first iron man
film we watch the self-centered arms
dealer happily selling whatever he can
to the army so that those in the middle
east can carry out warfare however upon
seeing the damage that his weapons do
firsthand he decides instead to use his
talents to make the world better and
because of this he's a fascinating
character to watch tony in many ways
represents us all and because of this
many people find him easy to relate to
now though we're not billionaires that
live lavish lifestyles i'm sure many of
you watching this grew up putting
yourself first even to the detriment of
others however as we tend to get older
and our priorities change we also see
how much of a negative effect that this
can have on the world and those around
us tony realizing his mistakes in
crawling out of a literal and
metaphorical cave turns him into the
hero iron man and this rebirth and
resurrection is just as important as his
death now tony's final farewell in
avengers end game feels absolutely
perfect another character going out this
way wasn't initially part of the plan
it's difficult to think of any way that
he could have had a better send off when
we look at the mcu as a whole it's very
much about tony trying to improve the
world around him sacrificing himself so
that others can have a better life the
first film of course shows us through
the idea of him very much giving up the
wealth and fortune that he would make
from dealing weapons however the playboy
persona still has a foot in the game and
this has brought up in avengers when
captain america says that he wouldn't
ever make a sacrifice play tony
definitely shows cap that he would and
come the end of the film he flies up
into the sky with a nuke potentially to
his death
though tony manages to come back he
shows that he would lay down his life if
it came to it and for the next 10 years
or so he's happy to throw himself in a
battle however come the snap things
change though tony survives the battle
with thanos he ends up adrift in space
for several weeks until he's rescued by
captain marvel believing that he's going
to die out there all that he leaves
behind is a recording for peppa potts to
tell her that he loves her however he's
saved and i think that this journey very
much changes him the snap pretty much
took something away from everyone except
for tony whilst most people lost the
ones that they loved peppa survived and
because of this the pair got to have a
daughter together i think that watching
those around him die and knowing that
she could have gone the same way makes
him realize what he almost lost and thus
he holds on to her even tighter tony
quits being iron man and it's a safe
assumption to make that he steps away
from the persona for five years this is
something that he toyed with in the past
and come the end of iron man 3 tony
threw his ark reactor into the ocean to
show that he was done with the role this
was to be with pepper become civil war
we discovered that he couldn't quit tony
had this compulsion to go out there but
after the snap he realized that she was
more important to him than being a hero
he ended up retreating to a country home
and here he raised a family tony had
once more become the selfish and
self-centered person who even refused to
help stephen co when they said there was
a way to fix everything tony just wanted
to be left alone but he knew that deep
down he wouldn't be able to rest if it
meant others wouldn't get to have the
love that he'd found with his family
with peppa's blessing tony returned to
the avengers compound buried the hatchet
with cap and he helped to launch a time
heist to get the infinity stones
although black widow died and nebula was
captured the mission itself was somewhat
a success the avengers managed to bring
everyone back but through the quantum
tunnel came an even more ruthless
version of thanos with the knowledge of
what happens in the aftermath of the
snap he decided to change the plan and
wipe out all of life instead of just 50
of it the final active avengers endgame
is an incredible one and the two sides
throw themselves at each other until
there's just two people left standing
this is thanos and tony now thanos feels
like he's completely unbeatable and
infinity war set him up as an inevitable
force that would power through
everything thrown at him because of his
will to complete this snap guy just had
no chill and after he beats everyone he
manages to get the stones in gauntlet so
that he can carry it out once more now
this is where tony steps in throughout
both infinity war and end game i very
much feel like he knew he would be the
one to stop thanos and that he'd likely
die doing this in infinity war doctor
strange saw over 14 million timelines
and he stated that there was only one in
which they won the wizard even
sacrificed himself and the time stone to
save tony's life and deep down i think
tony knew he'd only do this if it was
necessary become the final battle and
tony asks strange to tell him if they're
in the timeline where they win but
strange very much withholds this
information in case it doesn't happen
tony is a smart guy and to me he clearly
knows that he's going to be the person
who has to go out and make the sacrifice
play no matter how painful it is as
thanos collects the stones tony looks
over the strange who holds up one finger
to symbolize this being the one timeline
tony has one choice and he throws
himself forward and takes the stones
from thanos at this point thanos boasts
and gets one of the biggest fuse when he
realizes that he doesn't have the stones
it's a moment that still makes me fist
punch the air as watching his hubris
lead to his failure never gets old kurta
tony who now has the stones and in
response to thanos saying i am
inevitable tony says i am iron man now
this is an incredible moment that pays
off all the more because it's been
something that tony has added at several
key points he of course said it at the
end of iron man his first film and at
the end of iron man 3 which concluded
his trilogy tony zom has also taken a
lot of focus throughout the mcu and thus
having him holding it up in frame to
carry out the snap means a lot more now
this is because the first time that we
see tony in the mcu we open on his hand
holding a glass of scotch in the back of
the fun bee this very much represents
the self-centered hedonistic attitude he
has and how he doesn't really take
things seriously juxtaposing this tony
holding up his hand to carry out the
snap shows just how far he's come from
being selfish to selfless he perfectly
capitalizes on his arc throughout the
mcu and it's the perfect way to say
goodbye to the character here he
embodies what it means to be a hero and
how the real ones will sacrifice
themselves in order to make things
better for others he saves not only his
daughter and wife but also those who
lost the ones they loved and though the
character dies it's difficult to think
if there's any other way that he could
have gone out in a time where things
fail to stick to landing more times than
not it's actually nice to see a
character get the send-off that they
deserve tony stark very much saved this
universe and to see him being the one
that saves it shows how important he is
to everything robert downey jr goes out
in a triumphant moment with a character
that gave him a second chance and i
absolutely love this scene for all that
it stands for tony very much represents
that even with our less admirable traits
that we can still do good when it comes
down to it and that there lies within us
the ability to be heroic we just need to
make the choice to put others before
ourselves and tony is very much an
inspiration for the audience to keep
this in mind when making difficult
decisions it's an incredible send-off to
the character i think it's definitely
the perfect way for us to say goodbye to
him it makes avengers end game one of
the best comic book movies of all time
and of course love to hear your thoughts
on the scene in the comments below if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the perfect scene in spider-man into the
spider-verse which will be linked on
screen right now we went over the big
leap of faith what's up danger one and
it's one of our best videos a thing that
we've ever put together hopefully i see
over there right after this but if not
you take care of yourself and i hope you
enjoy the rest of your day i've been
paul you've been the best i'll see you
on the next one take care peace